I am glad that in this administration we
have increased the amount of money for
handling the problem of dangerous drugs
Sevenfold it will be six hundred million
dollars this year more money will be
needed in the future I want to say
however that despite our budget problems
to the extent money can help in meeting
the problem of dangerous drugs it will
be available this is one area where we
cannot have budget cuts because we must
wage what I have called total war
against public enemy number one in the
United States the problem of dangerous
drugs
it's a no-knock ray don't be afraid
we'll shoot your dogs in front of your
kids cuz we are the SWAT we're here for
your part and all the catch that you've
got we are adrenaline junkies taking
orders from the top
the KGB and a DEA
they'll make you disappear like in one
Tana MoBay
nothing to say if we get the wrong
address it doesn't matter
we'll still get our checks we'll still
have our fire
yeah we are the SWAT we are gentlemen
so the drugs are gone it's a known
be a friend
only stay
it's a No
and don't
and it's unknown
it's a No
don't be afraid
this is a war and this is your fate we
are the face of your new Poli States we
are the law and we've got the guns
statutory power mandatory minimums
we are the SWAT we're here for your
party
all cash that you've got we are at
junkies taking orders from the Czar and
some know
don't be afraid power melons
the rain it's a loan
don't be afraid
all your facts
and it's
don't be afraid
we stay
flashbang on
I hear a sound could be
that is unknown
it's a known
don't be afraid
you